hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on foreign Oregon and
today we have tons of info to talk about
in terms of armor sets the state of
balance recap and a lot more things
coming in the future so with that let's
get started let's not waste any time so
for the armor sets the twelve original
heroes of the game are gonna be getting
a new set of armor with three different
variations and the sixth DLC heroes sent
gladiator Highlander shaman shinobi and
our Musha will be getting a new
variation of their four existing sets
these were not shown sadly in the stream
maybe next week or something like that
but first they showed off the samurai
armor and like I said we're gonna begin
some new armor and these look menacing
the first I'm showing is Ken today's new
gear which has lots of lots to do with
lots of rope everywhere tons of variety
in the set and hair piece and the mask
it just looks really great and I'm
definitely excited I'm probably not
gonna be hoppin Honda Ken say any time
soon but any Ken say means definitely
won't enjoy these pieces of armor next
was shoe goki and he's looking mighty
thick might I add chest exposed facemask
is minimal lots of skulls surrounding
his outfit I'm glad we were able to see
his face and his thick body cuz we
haven't been able to seen that ever
since the beginning of the game so now
we could kind of put a face to the voice
and stuff like that and I'm also very
excited to see this armor and a lot of
people rocking this in the future
now bushi was next and she's actually
unmasked in this armor which is very
representative of an early fan art of
the character I don't remember the image
and I probably will most likely not find
it when I edit this video but I do
remember her looking very similar to
that type of fan art and the hat is a
little bit smaller in size they wanted
to go for a more materialistic look and
a fighter outfit but I definitely like
this and even if the outfit isn't that
great you do get to see her unmasked
with a face so that is definitely a plus
and then last for the samurai was Orochi
also he got some nice-looking armor
still covering the face but you know
with a little bit less clarity on that
also looking a lot cooler
I'm glad the team is also going away
from the more spikes look and going
all-out on these pieces giving it a more
military type feel because I'm pretty
sure everybody hates just having a
thousand spikes all over your armor and
it consider at a high level gear next
for the Knights and lob ringer was first
in terms of the armor for the Knights
and there's gonna be a lot more plating
around the arms and legs on these making
him more look like a tank which is nice
he also has a cape on the back as well
and looks a very menacing lots of holes
in the mask and stuff like that there's
a few spikes on some of his armor but
it's really not that
- crazy but he definitely has a cave
which is really nice to look at
conqueror was next you could see just a
little bit of his face so they took a
little bit away of the face mask a lot
more leather in the armor and a skull
mask on one of the sets as well
definitely a fan of the very simplistic
military style I probably said that
about four times already but I do really
like this I'm not big on the flashy
stuff this is a nice change afterwards
was warden and you can see a peek of his
face as well through the front of his
face mask just like conker and the
previous person we talked about no bushi
or og stuff like that
lots of leather and chainmail on these
types of armor sets as well with the
occasional gold colour being on there as
well as some metal now and then lastly
is peacekeeper and she's also unmasked
so I wonder if this is a type of girl
trend I mean I'm cool with it regardless
though but also more leather armour and
lots of other spikes on her armor and
stuff like that and a few different
hairstyles on the piece of the headpiece
as well but like I said even if you do
not like the armor though the most
important fact I think about this is the
fact that she doesn't have a mask
anymore so it's really cool to put a
face to the voice and stuff like that so
I'm really intrigued that they're doing
this more often
sadly only these were the two factions
shown for this stream next week they
said they are going to be taking a look
at the Viking and the Wulin armor so
don't worry a Viking brethren you
weren't left out you're gonna be talked
about next week as well as with the
Wulin characters we could see a lot more
of that so stay tuned next week for the
Deaf stream and especially my video
recapping it all for that on top of that
there's also a new mode coming it's a
training mode feature called hero
tactics and this is going to be added in
the hero menu very similar to training
arena except it's a more in-depth
tutorial on how on the hero you pick
these give you some of the character
options and moves you can incorporate
with that so for example if you have a
character that does soft faints it will
show you the moves that you can use that
saw faint with so for example shaman she
has a soft face where all you have to do
is tap the heavy button and then click
the like button and it will do a soft
faint bleed attack it will basically
show you those moves in any other moves
variety like that to pull off that soft
faint to help new players learn a lot
more about the character and advanced
players to maybe learn a few things that
didn't know or perfect their skills in
the training arena and it also tells you
if you complete a move or mess up and
move so you know if you're doing this
correctly or not which is a really nice
change and I like that they're adding
more to this training arena the new
content of the week is an autumn fall
effect very similar to a few the other
effects we've had like from the
Valentine's Day where the hearts come up
except this is now with a lot of leaves
really nice I'll play that in the
background while I talk but it's going
to I don't remember what the steel count
is but I'm assuming this might be a
limited time thing as well since this is
an autumn thing and fall is only for
only a couple months of the year so I'm
assuming this will only be for a limited
time so you might want to grab that as
you can but do not quote me on that
lastly to end the video we have the
state of balance recap for season 6 now
a lot of you have probably seen all the
youtubers complaining about it and I was
definitely one of them at least you know
behind the scenes and stuff like that
and I was sitting in my room complaining
about it but the devs wanted to
basically talk about it and that we may
have misinterpreted some of the
information now the huge thing is that a
lot of people are complaining that the
devs think qu Voki Wahlburgers and
Centurion are top tier characters that
is not the case they just think that
shougo key law burger and sent are top
tier characters in terms of contouring
scent and stuff like that they
understand that they're actually one of
the worst and they're definitely not the
best characters in the game but that
doesn't excuse the fact that they said
that law bringer is most likely not
going to have a rework because he's not
their first priority
gladiator zone is good but not good
enough which means he might get a buff
on that which is a no good and the light
spam in this game is only just a tactic
that you should learn how to block and
if you ever plan on console you
completely understand how bad light spam
is which doesn't make any sense to me at
all
but there is a plus coming from all of
this data in the 4v4 mode and the the
deficit explained this as well that
shikou key is planning on being a
reworked right now for the next rework
or buffs
there was no statement on when that will
come out whether it be season 8 or
season 9 or halfway through one of the
seasons but shikko key is definitely
being worked on right now and should be
in line for the next react which is very
interesting to hear should go humans are
gonna be crying once thick once this
river comes out because it's been way
too long and thick boy needs a rework
but let me know your thoughts on all
about this the season reading of the
seasons data balanced recap the armor
everything in this video I'd love to
know your thoughts but that guys like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe for new
I cover the information outside of
phoner that being balanced changes hero
updates patch notes leaks news
information about all about for honor
and with that my two most recent videos
would be on screen in a bit if you guys
do want to check that out went there
guys so whoever agrees today thank you
for watching the video and peace out
every day
[Music]
you
[Music]